GPS satellites on man drones for King
laser sights the more cruelty you have
the more ears when they kicked out from
under you
if there's one thing I know for sure if
the de six-inch blade never loses
reception when I was little myself -
taught me that silence was a woman's
best garment but I have to admit I never
really took her advice to heart when you
mix fuel metal oxide and metal powder in
just the right way it burns at 2,000
degrees Celsius hot enough to cut
through nearly any barrier known to man
throw some c4 into the mix and you've
got one hell of a combination
you have a few spare hours I'd love to
share the details on how this device is
a masterpiece of design credible
independent gearboxes enabling zero to
20 in under four seconds ten kilometers
of internal wiring 1,100 expertly
machine and assemble components who all
is control elephant 300 meters but all
my team needs to know is does it do the
job or doesn't it and let me tell you
right now it does the job
stay down
do you know what an artist and a sniper
have in common
details like when a touch of color is
out of place when the shadow does not
match with its surroundings or when a
shape is not where it is supposed to be
the only difference is the stakes
minor higher
you
you